i mean it also felt like after what  alidazza got out of the opening this  incredibly overwhelming uh attack  it looked that he gonna crash and then  all of a sudden uh ali got into trouble  after  anish was defending fantastically but it  just did not feel like anish also  deserves to win the game because uh  because ali had such a dominating attack  earlier yeah and yeah we see that  finally the game ends in a do and i  think both players can live with this  and look at ali reza he seems quite  relieved and happy with the way things  have ended uh also regardless of what  our eval bar said those moves that  needed to be found were so computer-ish  they were so difficult from a human  perspective to make those little moves  that kept the advantage going